- Yeah, how are you?
- I'm good.
I feel like I should go
to the gym after hugging you.
Like when we hugged, I was like,
"This is like hugging Lester, my drummer."
It's like a,
just a brick wall, man.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- Do you just work out all the time?
Don't say genetics. I'll slap you.
Don't you do it.
- Ge... I work out a lot.
(audience laughing)
- Thank you.
- And when I work out,
- You lie.
- when I work out it feels like
there's a musical theme going on.
- Yeah?
- With the brothers up there.
Thank you all for your service,
first and foremost.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
And Kelly.
- Yeah?
- I would have you know
that when I work out,
- Oh, what's happening?
what is on my playlist.
- I wanna know.
I love that, by the way.
- Since I was a boy.
- No, you did not just
pull up that record.
(Kelly laughing)
- You are it now.
♪ Here's the thing ♪
♪ We started out friends ♪
♪ It was cool but it was just pretend ♪
- Oh, my God.
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
- You work out to this?
- This is me.
♪ Since you been gone ♪
(audience clapping and cheering)
♪ Just a kid that took the time ♪
- Just so you know,
♪ Wasn't long ♪
this is me.
♪ 'Til I called you mine ♪
(audience laughing)
- Yep.
- It's a great song.
- Is it?
- It's still a great song.
It's a great song.
(audience cheering)